[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو وحيد من موسكو يقولون هذه
الصور انها منظومه
للدفاع الجوي الروسيه
في العاصمه موسكو مقارنه الصور تقول ان
المنظومه نشرت على سطح وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لكن تقارير تفيد بان القوات
الروسيه نشرت هذه المنظومه ايضا على عدد
من المواقع الحساسه في العاصمه بدايه فان
هذه المنظومه مخصصه لاسقاط صواريخ كروز
والقنابل الموجهه والمسيرات يستطيع نظام
الرادار فيها رصد الاهداف على بعد 30 كلم
يرصد 20 هدفا ويشتبك مع اربعه في الوقت
نفسه في الاعلانات الرسميه تكشف وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن اجراء تدريبات لوحدات
الدفاع الجوي في العاصمه تحاكي التدريبات
صدها جماعه المفترضه على المنشات صناعيه
وعسكريه
التدريبات هذه المنظمات اس 3 للدفاع الجوي
الروسيه الشهيره هل هي مجرد تدريبات
بروتينيه ام تمت الطلاق رفض الكرملين
الافصاح عن ما اذا كانت البلاد تتحضر
لهجمات المحتمله سالته وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه فاحل الامر الى وزاره الدفاع
التي لم ترد على السؤال هذا الفيديو نشره
مستشار وزير الداخليه الاوكراني ويقول انه
صور قبل اسبوعين يشير الفيديو وفقا
المسؤول الاخرانيه الى مضاد للطائرات
بالقرب من منزل الرئيس الروسي في التحليل
يقول المتابعون العسكريون ان روسيا اما
انها قلقه من هجمات اوكرانيه على العاصمه
او ان في الامر بوادر ازمه داخليه على شكل
انقلاب عسكري على الرئيس الروسي كل هذه
المعلومات والتحليلات لا تخرج عن سياق
الدعم الغربي لكيف الاحاديث المتواتره
كذلك عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تتحضر لشنها
جماعه في العمق الروسيه بحلول الربيع تتهم
موسكو القوات الاوكرانيه بالوقوف وراءها
هجمات بطائرات مسيره على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه في انقل اراد الروسيه لا تهديدات
الرسميه اوكرانيه حتى الان بشان هجمات
شرقيه الحدود الا ان القوات الاخرانيه
تقول انها تعتبر جزيره القرم جزء من
اراضيها ولن تتوقف عن استهداف القوات
الروسيه فيها تلك جزيره تسيطر عليها روسيا
منذ عام 2014 ويعتبر الهجوم الاوكراني
وعليها تحولا تستراتيجيه القوات
الاوكرانيه من الدفاع الى الهجوم السؤال
الان هل ستسمع سفارات الانذار في العاصمه
الروسيه كما سمعت في نظيرتها الاوكرانيه
يوم الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي